i think we're live
and you are speaking better so you
should mute your microphone
um hi guys i don't know if you can hear
me and see me
the live started a little bit earlier or
so we're doing some checks
to see if everything is looking properly
i cannot see questions so what i have to
do
i guess is i have to go to my youtube
page
and wait a second wait a second
oh here it is
let me just check and just check
hi melissa hi hi guys
everything is good luca says christoph
or
stuff i think it's it's because it's uh
it's polish let me do
yes okay everything is working properly
i think we're almost ready to go in
three minutes we're going to start
the live officially i just wanted to
tell you that i have as usual selected
a couple of questions that i um
you know you guys have been kind enough
to send me
in advance so i'll go through those and
of course i'll go through all the
questions
you're going to ask in this live or
almost all the questions or just a part
of
the questions because normally i cannot
keep up
honestly with how many questions do you
ask do
you ask someone asks
it's going well as you can imagine here
the weather is beautiful there's a lot
of light
uh it's uh it's a very nice time to be
in rome but in a little bit i will fly
to munich
and then off to poland so this is the
last sounds a little bit dramatic this
is the last
um live from
rome and then i will probably bring
carry my equipment or
uh you know i'll i will make do uh
to uh stream live from other parts of
europe the next one
the next q a is going to be in spanish
so this is the last one
of the batch of five live sessions
in english and then we're gonna do some
spanish for those who speak spanish or
for those who are
learning spanish hi guys um
so what's a guilty pleasure of yours
gelato just like right around the corner
i go and grab my ice cream
so um let me see here questions started
pouring in
happy to join another one of your lives
i really enjoy that thanks i really
enjoy talking to you guys
it's a real pleasure so
i would start to oh one last
thing i want to say uh bert and kevin
they're uh
my friends and they you know they work
with me they're going to moderate the
chat
as usual if you can please post comments
in english and um do not post the same
questions over and over
because it you know messes up the chat a
little bit
having said that we still have one
minute ago before we start
with the questions uh hola la saludos
deste peru
venezura in peru
is irresistible to most human beings i
do know some people don't like gelato
but
you know for the for for the life of me
i had to stop because i liked like
the gelateria or gelateria and italian
around the corner is one of the best in
rome and
and it's more than a guilty pleasure you
know just
it it it becomes it gets crazy if you
start then
you know as far as i'm concerned when i
start i never stop so that's my problem
hello from lisbon hello from rome uh
sergio says hi to kevin i did an
interesting question let's start with
this one that has nothing to do with
language journey do you dance
yes i like moving my body to the music
but i'm not a dancer in the sense i've
never learned to professionally dance or
anything
but yes i i do like dancing um
so let's start with a couple of
questions here and then i'm going to
move to
some of the questions that i have on
this piece of paper hi luca have you
read
books in hungarian i have started
reading
a book in hungarian but i haven't read a
lot of them i tried to read simple
things but i just realized that
reading books in hungarian still too
difficult i think i read two years ago
a bilingual book english hungarian i
should have it somewhere there but
for those who want to read start reading
books in literature in another language
i always
recommend either that you read a simple
book or a book you you
have already read or a bilingual book
something that is comprehensible because
reading books especially non-fiction
books is quite
difficult so
marco de martino asks me in italian i
ask you guys if you can if you can
uh ask questions in uh in english but
you know i'll i'll translate because
hi luca i was wondering what do you
think about your own mother tongue
italian
do you have some maintenance strategies
well i read the newspaper every day
and i occasionally read books in italian
and i talk to my friends and family in
rome
but the truth is that if you want to
keep italian to a very high level
if you want to keep a very high standard
in your own native language you have to
proactively work on it the fact that
it's your own native language does not
guarantee
that you're able to keep the same level
because
every single language the grades
if you do not use it so in my case i
read a lot i read the newspapers
especially because i read a lot of
nonfiction books in
english but i i try to keep italian
you know i try to to stick to it because
italian is my native language it's an
important one
so it's as important as all the others
now let's um address some of the
questions here
on the the first one is luik bondwa i
think he's french
but he uh opens this question by chesh
luca which is polish
hi luca what's the biggest challenge you
faced when learning polish and how did
you overcome it thank you so much for
the work you're doing and for spreading
the
love for language learning thanks a
bunch louie for the
interesting question i think that the
biggest challenge when learning polish
or any other language
is actually to keep learning over the
long term i remember that i had been
learning
i started learning polish in 2012
i think after i went to poznan and then
i i was very enthusiastic but
like everything then the enthusiasm
wanes and tapers off a little bit if you
don't have the chance of practicing the
language so i do remember that
i was not lost but i was losing
motivation because i had been
you know in poland but then i didn't go
back and then i told myself the only way
to keep my motivation high for me is to
engage with people to to know to have
experiences to get to know people to
to talk with them to live with them to
interact eat
and whatnot and so i decided to go back
to poland
to and and create you know
make friends make friends with people
and that helped me so
i would say that the language had some
challenges
but the main challenge was to stick to
the language because they do believe
that if you love a language no matter
how difficult it is or
you know how complicated it is you're
going to learn it
if you really want to you know speak
fluently in order to have
meaningful a meaningful communication
with the people
you you you you will interact with
jack c hey luca can you tell us what is
typically causing you trouble when
learning a new foreign language
remembering words listening word order
idioms and cultural
references be specific please thanks
i would say that the thing that causes
the most problem is
actually syntax so syntax is this nice
um a word that linguists use to
describe how language is how you
actually formulate your thoughts how you
form sentences
in in a foreign language and i found it
particularly difficult i made a video
maybe kevin can post this video
my failure in learning japanese or
something along those lines i don't
remember the exact title where i
i said that one of the most difficult
things that
kept me from learning fluently i kept me
from learning the language and acquiring
fluency
was the fact that japanese has a very
unusual or better a very different
word order right for example if you say
i want to go to japan they say japan
particle go to want you know it's a
completely
different way of forming sentences and
since i had applied the same method to
learn any other language and i was not
used to a new
aspect to this new aspect of the
specific language family
japanese actually is a unique language
in this regard but it has a very similar
structure
like for example korean has a similar
structure and turkish as well
then i found it quite difficult so that
was the thing that was really difficult
every language every new language i
learned has
some specific quirks or features that
make it a little bit
more difficult but all in all as i said
before if you want to learn
this language you will you will make it
happen no matter what
so now i will address these questions
but now i'll
see here some of the questions um
let me see here um tony christo what are
your thoughts on trying to get perfect
in your target language well my thoughts
or my thought is that perfection is just
an illusion
so i think you should ban the word
perfect when it comes to human beings
humanity you can get good
but perfect there is no such thing as of
of perfection so
i i don't think i don't think you should
strive for perfection you should strive
to be the better version of yourself
every single day that you can strive
for but as for perfection for perfection
i i don't think that uh there's
such a concept in within the
you know the human all the human
activities so and i also believe that
perfectionism can actually backfire if
you're too if you want to be too perfect
then
um actually sometimes some people
refrain
from taking action and engaging with
people just out of fear of making
mistakes so
um if you get into the mindset of
banning
of completely eliminating the concept of
being perfect or perfectionism then it's
liberating
and you can do a bunch of stuff in
language learning and in life in general
so what do you think about anki
uh julio lothano i think that's his name
i do not know anki i know this
i know of the system i know the space
repetition uh
concept behind anki super memo and
whatnot
but i have never used flash cards and
i'm happy that i've never used flash
cards
so i gotta confess that i don't know
much about it but i do have a lot of
students that use anki and after using
the system that i propose then they move
off away from monkey and use a different
system i use notebooks and i
use handwriting and a completely
different way of reviewing things that
is not overwhelming i
have already filmed a video that is
going to come out
i don't know when but probably in a few
weeks about what i do to remember words
so stay tuned um
melissa zan this is a very interesting
question how do you know
when you reached a good enough fluency
11 and language to be able to move on to
another
well i normally
know once i've that that i've reached a
level when i start having conversation i
start
actually feeling confident and
comfortable with the language that's the
moment where psychologically i tell
myself i've reached this level actually
i see
every single language that you learn as
a story
that you build and once you've built a
character to a certain point then the
story
is is is good enough is advanced enough
that i can
open so to speak and i can start a new
one
so for me it's not so much a matter of
how many words i know it's more about
the experiences that i have
that actually determines whether i
consider this language
good enough so that i can integrate it
in my life and in my specific case
it's about you know having experiences
going to the country or
you know finding myself in a situation
where i can actually
have a conversation without any problem
i i remember to this
uh to this point actually um an
interesting episode that happened
a few weeks ago i've been learning greek
for about
four years and i've always
you will see me guys speak with my uh
lovely
um greek tutor because we're we're going
to make a video
in greek uh so you will see how i
actually engage and how i learn but
i've been speaking mostly with her and
and it was funny because um a friend of
mine
you know she was here for a little bit
and then she just
told me hey i got a surprise she she
rushed into my room and she gave me the
telephone
and you know the other side there was a
greek guy and i had to speak greek
off the cuff right and i was like oh
this is the first time
we're all scared of the first time we
speak in a real life
situation but i happen to have a very
nice
conversation i'll be a little bit short
but i just realized
damn i i can actually speak greek i can
communicate outside of this
language learning bubble right you when
you have a tutor in a friendly situation
it's it's easier but then i found myself
you know i had to speak the language and
i realized oh this is the point
where i can move on to another language
so for me
it's a more like a psychological thing
rather than language prowess
prowess rather than the words i know
it's the experiences that shape
my decisions to move to another language
i hope this makes sense so
let me see here
i saw some question about the
bi-directional translation but now i
lost it because i have to go up
so let me see um
can you sound native in italian i've
heard that it's very difficult to sound
natives
asks amalia i'm going up with the
questions um
i've i've heard a couple of people uh
who to me sound completely native and
italian one is a
as a famous polish actress i think her
name is smoothnyak if i'm not wrong
i thought she was that she was raised in
italy but she's actually polish
and she was raised in poland she speaks
perfect italian actually her italian is
so refined
that it's she's an actress but it's just
incredible the way she speaks and
also on the channel easy italian i don't
know if you guys know easy italian i'm
pretty sure you do
there's um a fantastic girl who lives in
milan she shoots videos
in italian and her italian is top notch
you can
tell maybe sometimes from her um
you know from the way she formulates
certain sentences that she's not italian
but i do remember that i met her in
bratislava i didn't even know who she
was and i just i was just
wow like you sound completely italian so
it's possible
although rare but you have to ask
yourself do you want to sound italian
and why that's that's a more important
question so it's possible
there are a few individuals who pull
that off but it's
it's rare you know it there has there
has to be a special alignment of factors
for that to happen
so lucas jensen luca how's it going
danish do you find yourself
wanting to speak swedish hildsner
denmark so greetings from denmark
yes i would say danish is going well i'm
gonna post a video
this week or next week i don't know if
you guys noticed that i started
publishing again on longer videos on
thursdays and then i'm gonna publish
also the short video so we're gonna have
mondays and thursdays
and i'm going to publish a video about
my updates for 2021
including danish danish is going well
but it's a little bit on the back burner
meaning that now i'm focusing more on
especially in greek and hungarian
i have hired a tutor i've had around 10
lessons or something like that and when
i speak danish yes i want to speak
swedish
my my tutor tells me that i i speak i
speak
swedish i mean i speak danish with a
swedish accent which doesn't surprise me
at all so
we were talking about the fact that when
when you know already know a language
within the same family
it's a double-edged sword on the one
hand it really helps because sometimes
you just
completely invent words completely and
they happen to be correct because the
two languages are very similar
but i also have a lot of interference
because obviously
swedish is dominant and my danish is
still a little bit
you know let's say not particularly
solid
just yet but i do enjoy talking to my
twitter and we have decided actually
we had a nice chat last week we would
like to have to show you guys
how these conversations unfold if you
guys want to watch uh
you know i want to see how i actually
learned with tutors
i'm preparing stuff with greek hungarian
and danish
um nazi look what do you think about
for dummies books for learning languages
i gotta confess
uh manan that i do not know these books
i mean
i know of them but i've never used them
i've never read them so
i i can't tell tell you much about that
um so
tell us please something about
interpreter anish joshi i'm not sure
what
you are what you mean by that maybe
about my my career or my experience as
an interpreter
but i'm not quite sure so um
karen's the hortio when it comes to
maintaining your languages guys
you just ask so many interesting
questions that it's difficult not to go
through
them one by one but i'm trying to do my
best to answer all of them
when it comes to maintaining your
languages do you choose to focus more on
one for a period of time a month for
greater spanish month for polish
thanks been watching for years um
well i i talked about this uh before
but fundamentally i designed a life
where i happen to maintain
let's say between six and eight
languages i actually happen to practice
slash use slash enjoy eight between five
and eight languages every single week
and then i have four languages that
they are in the back burger i don't use
that much and then i'm actively learning
greek hungarian and danish so there's
more or less eight languages on
maintenance mode four languages that are
in the back burner that i use very
occasionally well i'll i'd say i'd
rather say rarely and then i have three
languages that i'm actively
um you know learning so it's not that i
do one language and then i forget about
the other one the problem is that the
more languages you speak the more
you know the easier it gets to learn
them on the one hand but the more
difficult it becomes to maintain all
these languages so
if you don't design a life where you
happen to use these languages on a daily
basis or some of these languages that
you have under your belt then inevitably
it's going to be difficult
and trying to focus on one for a month
and then trying to focus on the other
one for a month is just going to confuse
my
brain you have to tell your brain you
have to signal to your brain somehow
that the languages that you have in your
head are important
and the best way is to have you know
frequent
contact with these languages which
implies that you should
you know have contact use these
languages and by using i don't mean you
have to
necessarily talk you can watch and use
you can read something
at least every other day otherwise your
brain really does get confused and says
what the hell now spanish for a month
and then polish and
you know it becomes a little bit messy
so that's the tricky part of
being multilingual after three four or
five languages it becomes tricky
um do you use any app to practice your
speaking
what's up so if there is an app i don't
use a language learning app but i do use
whatsapp so
first thing in the morning for example
if i
want to go i've been doing this for a
little bit now i have to change habits
again because it's taking too long but
i just wake up i make the bed and then i
go
and i go and grab a cup of coffee and
while i go there
you know i just send messages in greek
or in hungarian or some other languages
so
it i'm practicing the language i'm
sending messages to friends and then i
get messages back
that's my if you want to call it an app
i don't think that whatsapp is exactly
an app for language learning but i
use it as a tool to practice spoken
languages
in the past maybe some 10 years ago
i was engaging in chats like i was going
to these websites there's a website i
can't remember the name
but but it was bought by rosetta stone
and
you could chat with everyone but then i
just realized that chatting is too slow
and i
i very much prefer actually speaking
with people and with friends with whom i
can engage
in a longer conversation the problem
sometimes is that if you
chat there's a lot of people to talk to
but if you channel the time
you always resort to the same questions
and the same answers what's your name
where are you from and that becomes a
little bit limiting so if you
on the other hand find someone you can
have a
longer and more meaningful communication
not not
live necessarily but you can send
messages first thing in the morning or
at night or whenever you want you want
that to me is more useful but
i don't use many language apps i don't
think i've ever used any app in my
whole life i have used platforms
like link for example l i n g q by
legendary steve kaufman
but i i've never really used the app you
know or any apps that come with the
platform i've always used the platform
platform as a way to grab resources and
use them offline
uh so
let me see how can i integrate the
bi-directional translation method into a
busy schedule
i'm stub bum hey guy i think you man you
you got a very complicated anyway i
can't pronounce it
um so yeah this is the question i was
trying to answer before
and before everything fell apart and i
couldn't find anything else
here in the chat um i would say
um the bi-directional translation first
it's important to know exactly how that
works i've made a recently i've made um
you know a live course about that and
i've realized that a lot of people
actually do not know exactly
how this works because i have uh
left some some free advice there is some
there are some free videos and articles
on the internet but they're not
very they don't go in depth so that's
the first thing you have to know how to
do it the second thing is that
you know this question goes for any
learner
and for any language and for every
routine i think that if you want to
apply this language
first you have to create the mental
space to make it happen the
bi-directional translation
has a lot of benefits but the main
problem is that if you wanna
if you want it to kick in if you want it
to be very efficient you have to
dedicate between 30 to 45 to even one
hour a day
60 minutes a day and you have to be
consistent and you have to do it for a
long period of time
so if you're ready to create that mental
space and actual mental and physical
space we're just gonna
you're gonna sit down and you're just
gonna make it happen then it's possible
otherwise if you keep telling yourself
that you're too busy maybe language
learning and the bi-directional
translation and whatnot they're not your
priority and i say this all the time to
all my
friends and students that if you want to
be serious about learning you have to
create that mental space so
if you start by saying i'm i'm very busy
which is true everyone is busy but if
you think about it
within our busy busy lives we always
manage to do things we like i don't know
hitting hitting the the gym or
go to the park or study watch a movie
etc etc so keep that in mind
um then what else how do you learn the
phonetics
phonetic sound in a foreign language i'm
not sure about the phonetic
i guess xd flow right you wanted to know
how to
learn the sounds of a foreign language
right the sound structure or formal
language i guess
i'm making assumptions here i've made a
couple of videos about that so kevin
maybe you can post
the youtube link and the link to the
articles
and i've talked about that that a lot in
the other q a
section so if if if you want you can go
back and and check
that sorry guys if you if i don't you
know spend too much time on this but
some of the questions you that keep you
know they keep happening they keep
popping up so i refer to what i've
already said before
marek uh hi luca thank you for all the
great
advices great pieces of advice uh thank
you marek
so ricardo scott
lucas i'm going to translate i'm an
engineering student as you were
and how can you cope with university and
language learning at the same time
well as i said before you just have to
design a schedule so in advance you tell
yourself okay how much time do i have
how much energy do i have and you sit
down and you plan your time this goes
for any anybody you know not just as
as an engineer um you know being an
engineer you know that
or you know you you going for a career
as an engineer you very well know that
it's
tough it's uh it's tough it requires a
lot of mental energy but if you plan
your time and you tell yourself i'm
gonna spend one hour
in the morning before i go to university
or in the evening
then you know you can make it happen i
remember that i learned chinese on the
bus
while commuting that was the last year
of university i told myself
you know i was preparing my thesis and
then
how how do i find time to learn chinese
well on the bus
one hour 45 minutes or one hour there
and i had to thank
the italian traffic jam for that
so i had all the time in the world to
alert of course it's not the same thing
as just sitting in a quiet room and
but you know i made it happen so you can
make it happen
if you if you know how to structure your
time
so what do you think about asimil well i
got a lot of
ass i got a lot of uh asimo books there
maybe you can't see it because the the
camera is pointing at me here
but uh i think that it's a fantastic
book and talk about it all the time
especially when it comes to
learning languages from scratch
sometimes for asian languages it's not
top-notch i very much prefer learning
european languages with asimil so i
would not recommend it for korean or
japanese
personally i haven't found it that
useful at least for japanese
but i think all in all it's a fantastic
language resource you can start learning
any language with
from scratch your microphone is cracking
luca
i'll try to i don't know what to do
about that
let me see if i stay you know this
distance if anything changes
uh what book do you recommend to learn
english
there's a lot of books i recommend to
learn english i would i would start
using asimo but if you're asking this
question
i guess that you already speak english
so i would say just read a bunch of
books and read a bunch of
you know articles and things that you
can understand so that you can improve
that's what i would say i don't think
you need necessarily a book to learn
english specifically but a book to books
or
resources or stuff you can read
interesting stuff
stuff that interests you to expand your
knowledge
and you as a consequence of that you
expand your
your language your level of english
do you have in hungarian i am not sure
um
what level but i can have conversations
without a problem with my tutor the
problem with hungarian is that as you
will see
i think that it's not going to be the
last the next one but probably in two
weeks so you will see
of me speaking hungarian you'll be able
to judge because there's going to be
subtitles in hungarian and in english
and i feel comfortable speaking
hungarian right now having conversations
with my tutor i was
in hungary a lot of times i'm still a
little bit frustrating about
not being able to understand the news
and i still find it difficult for
example to read books so i haven't i
think i don't
i haven't gotten to an extremely
advanced level
but it's because of the way i'm more in
maintenance mode
with hungarian so i do speak hungarian
twice a week with my tutors
for 30 minutes i kind of review the
notes but
not that much so it's really maintenance
mode and my level just
got you know kind of stalled a little
bit but
um you know i'm waiting for
uh for the borders to open so that i can
charge to hungary and
my dream is actually to live in budapest
because i'm absolutely infatuated with
how beautiful the city is
so as i always do right now i keep it
like i maintain this level
until i find the opportunity to make my
you know to make my level to improve my
level by
living the language and mind you going
to hungary means that if i go to hungary
and live in hungary i want to
i will try to do anything and everything
in order to make friends with
hungarians and speak the language and
have as many experiences as possible
because that
again is what makes us fluent that the
amount of experiences we have the amount
of people we talk to
uh the amount of times we take a walk we
go to the restroom we go to the city
when we have all sorts of experiences
that creates a
story line in our brain and i think that
when we speak a language
that our brain keeps this storyline
together
and gives us a sort of identity that for
me uh means fluency more than
the words that you know the sentences
you can alter
so um
how many languages would you say that
you really master and dominate as i said
before there is no such thing as
perfection or mastering anything a
language learning is like trying to
master a language just trying to grab
water with your hands you know falling
water with your hands you just can't
because the language changes all the
time not only does it change all the
time it changes
across the globe different people speak
in different ways
but it changes with time so every time
there's new words or
there are some words or cultural
references that change certain
generations
speak in a certain way so it's an ex
it's a it's a very
um elastic and an
entity that changes with time space and
and whatnot
so there is no such thing as mastering a
language you can master maybe
the phonetic system of a language of a
given part of a language or a specific
dialect of our language or the way a
certain language is spoken but there is
no such
thing as mastering the language having
said that i would say that
i feel comfortable i have created a
storyline
in my head i or better i i feel fluent
i feel comfortable speaking around 10
languages because
i lived multiple situations i got to
know people
i lived a lot of experiences and i
created this the storyline in my head
but
again i don't master these languages
not even italian you know and and the
the funny
the funny thing about this is the funny
part about this is that
you know when when we think that we know
a language
then we are um confront
and we're confronted with very
specialized texts of i don't know within
astronomy or specific things we realize
that there are so many technical terms
that you know we know just a tiny
portion of the language it might sound
surprising but with a tiny portion of
all the
existing words and all the existing
vocabulary within language we can do a
lot
so again um i think a lot of people are
obsessed with
this perfection perfectionism or
perfecting or
mastering but there's no such thing as
mastering the most important thing
for me at least my humble opinion is to
be able to communicate well in a
language
when people for example ask me or i see
some people saying luca speaks
english like a native or he doesn't i
don't i don't think i speak
like it like exactly like a native when
it comes to speaking any foreign
language
apart from italian but it doesn't matter
to me you know i always strive to
be the better version of myself in terms
of language skills or in terms of
personality and whatnot
but i recognize that i will never be
perfect i will never sound like a native
in any foreign language and it doesn't
really matter
so um
byron williams uh where did you get your
graded readers for french
well um i think i got it at fnak
you know fnak is like in paris i got a
lot of them at
fnak when i was directly there if you
write buck or libra
on amazon you can find quite a few but
if not there were there were a lot of
them
so i hope that answers your question
because i was directly in paris and it
was much easier to find
these books especially because in france
they produce them in other languages
or in other countries they don't or they
do less
so fewer actually they produce fewer
books of this kind
uh so let me see
chat only in english please please says
berta
that that will tell you off if you don't
write in english
um so let's let me see here
andre even luca what background one must
have before starting extensive reading
i'm not sure what you mean by background
i mean if you have to be an engineer and
an astronaut to start extensive reading
but you don't have to have any
background i would say that when it
comes to
you know language skills when it comes
to extensive reading maybe that was your
question
you have to have i think you have to
have a solid based on the language
especially if you want to engage
in books that are you know long and
that are for example literature fiction
and non-fiction
alike they're difficult so you have to
have a solid base in the language but
i think that to cover the gap or to
cover the bridge
i think we you should do you should find
resources like bilingual resources or
things you can't understand that are a
little bit
you know like these bilingual books that
i have in french
i don't know if i can find one
yes i think this one for example
byron was asking me before i hope that
you can see it from the camera because
this is a typical bilingual book i'm not
sure that you can
see it here maybe you can see it from
here but let me show you the cover so
this is edgar
allen poe three story three
short stories this is not actually that
easy
of a book to read but it's great because
you have it you know you have bilingual
you have the bilingual version you have
also the notes explaining so this is
something that you can start with you
also have some other books like this one
i think i showed it before this is very
cool these are graded readers
so i would say if you want to delve into
you know reading more extensively you
might want to use graded readers
look them up just write graded readers
on the internet you will find what this
is about
but the bottom line is just to build
your capacity of
of reading step by step and then you can
you know you can start reading
real books because reading real books
especially literature
narrative is particularly difficult
non-fiction is a little bit easier for a
number of reasons
before i delve into other questions i
have here a few others
hans law i think hans law he also really
wanted his answer
his questions answered he also was the
first one to
he he to to post this question here
so i i it's also on the paper so
um so you're still quite
young thank you i'm 40 i'm i'm not sure
if i'm particularly young but yes i'm
young yes
i'm young which languages of those you
don't speak now would you like to speak
20 30 years from now do you have some
magic number of languages
you've been aiming for 20 or 25
i don't think um about languages in
terms of numbers i think
uh about the number of experiences and
the number of things that
speaking languages can bring about in my
life so
i gotta tell you the truth i don't have
any number in mind i don't i don't wanna
i've never told myself hey by the age of
80 i'm just going to be speaking 50
languages numbers
are not really relevant to me i will
learn the languages along the path
it will happen i know that i will not
stop now i know that i will learn more
languages and i know that
again languages choose me and not the
other way around i will let languages
choose me
along my existential path so um
again i will learn a bunch of languages
but it doesn't really the the number
doesn't really matter
and uh also on how many languages do you
think
one intelligent person can speak on a
native
level five and on c one ten and on b
30. i again i
um it really depends on what you mean by
intelligent person
intelligence is a really a multifaceted
concept
what does it mean to be intelligent and
there's so many
uh so many factors i believe more like
in circumstances
and you know life circumstances and your
will of learning your attitude and a
number of other important factors
uh i made a video about that i think how
many languages can a man speak and i
think
kevin can put the the link in in the
in the video in the description i'm
sorry in the in the on the chat
uh but as i said that you know depending
i we
i thought i had a thought experiment and
i i thought about
a lady or a guy a human being traveling
every year to a different country and
learning spending time learning the
language before he goes
and lives in country maybe this person
can learn to speak 30 languages
fluently but the problem is always that
although i do believe that the brain has
an amazing
capacity of learning and we could hold
so much information in our head
the problem is that we're limited in
time and space and our memory
which is connected with space is limited
so
the more languages you learn the more
languages you have to
maintain and speak and whatnot so there
is
an upper limit but this limit is really
loosely
defined it's very fuzzy because of a
number of the number of factors involved
and i think at the end of the day
it's irrelevant um you know how many
ques
how many we we can think about we can
ask ourselves that
it's the human the human mind and
as humans we like asking questions about
our limits but the reality is that
language learning is not like
hey what's a record of whatever you know
the
the the number of meters a man has
jumped and the number of meters the
the mountain the highest mountain that a
human being has climbed and whatnot you
can't really measure
language learning the way you do these
things so at the end of the day i think
you can learn a bunch of languages
uh and you can speak a lot a bunch of
language as well
as long as you find yourself in the
right circumstances and
it's rare for an individual to speak
more than 10 15 languages
fluently because
of the limits of time space and memory
so uh nicolas turgat i've read
based on your suggestion can you suggest
me another great italian classic
i don't know nicola yeah you didn't say
if if you liked it
but my suggestion would be to read all
italo calvino's books because they're
just amazing
start with those ones gonna have enough
to read for the next six months
uh then you can ask me what's the next
what's and what's the next author
i should i should read in the next q a
or maybe in the next
in five q a's uh
so let me see um
ariana have you ever thought about
starting a language podcast yes i have
but there's so many things going on in
the background that i'm focusing on
um you know to on on other projects but
it's been it's been it's been in my mind
the back of my mind for quite some time
and i would
really i would be really glad to start a
language podcast
but one thing at a time i think probably
it's a it's a project for 2022. i just
told myself this year just do
with my team we just brainstormed that
one thing at a time because my problem
is that sometimes i'm so enthusiastic
that i would like to do podcasts and i
would like to do videos and then
and then life gets in the way and you
realize that time is limited and you
have so many resources and then you have
to choose and
focus on one thing at a time but it's an
excellent idea ariana
and sooner or later it is going to
happen
so uh
let me see vivion thanks so much for the
amazing content helped me a lot with
english portuguese
and now romanian how would you go about
less documented languages i would say
one piece of advice that i give when for
people who want to learn exotic
languages is to
find use the amazing tools that the
internet provides to find a native
speaker with that native speaker you can
you know
native speakers are incredible resources
we focus on a lot on a
which platform uh which book which
resource but actually when you talk to a
native speaker and you ask the right
questions they can point to amazing
resources
i don't know documentaries uh things
they can you can even ask them to create
your own material material in that
language for example with a friend of
mine
uh i'm asking her to create serbian
stuff in serbian for me because i've
just realized that in croatian you have
a lot of stuff but in
in serbian less sorbo cerberque is the
same language but
two different versions and i just asked
her hey
can you help me create the material so i
would say for and serbian is not even an
exotic language you know it's
kind of exotic but not that exotic so i
would say if you have the time
just do some research and find one
native speaker
one or two through the internet and then
ask them
politely if you learn by doing the stuff
that you like
so if you like listening to music if you
like watching a time movies if you like
literature
if you like anything italian and you
spend time
exploring that stuff through italian
then you will learn as a consequence of
that so
let me see
marco cuevas look i've developed the
habit of reading along with the
audiobook do you think
this is harmful i think it's fine if you
want to read along that's great
you're reading listening and um reading
along
so you're killing three birds with one
stone although truth be told i would say
that also
what you could do is to listen and read
at the same time and maybe sometimes you
can engage in this like
reading along but it's great i i think
it's it's good it's
it's you you should you should um
you should keep at it so
uh samuel fentus you're the best you
motivate me a lot
thank you so much and you guys motivate
me along with all these interesting
questions
so it's mutual um can you recommend any
media in polish
jay has a music podcast youtube channel
etc
so now off the cuff i can say
that there's a lot of stuff paulie mate
maybe kevin well polymath is like with
the y polymath is a very interesting
channel
makuovich just right makwovich it's an
amazing guy goes around i just watched
the video while i was eating
makovic is a guy who just shows
the world and the traditions and cooking
and he talks about stuff now he has
his own stuff because he was on the
national channel
and he has his own website he's just a
phenomenal guy
um i have actually if you go to the
resources
on the on the website and our website
lucanumber.com you can see some stuff
but now off the cuff i'm trying to think
uh about all the
the nice um all the nice youtube
videos if you want what we can do is
post them all
in the resource sections because i have
a lot i've been i've been consuming a
lot of resources in
in polish so i have at least five or six
youtube channels for you uh historia
bestsenzure
it's like history without uh without
censorship
literally translated that's another
another funny one they don't
this one doesn't have subtitles for most
of the time
my suggestion is to look for stuff that
has subtitles anyway um
due to the fact that to the lack of time
we can't i can't list all the resources
but
we will add give me a nice idea we're
going to add all this stuff because
there's really a lot of stuff there and
podcasts and
and youtube videos and tv shows and
whatnot
so we're gonna put them in the section
make sure that you check the section
within the next two weeks
two weeks um
michelle devitt during your first live q
a you told us you were going to paul in
the summer
you said it was the most interesting
country for euro at the moment
how come it's because i i love i just
love poland i i'm going to be in krakow
for three weeks then i'm going to watch
i'm going to
warso and i'm going to go around i just
like
being in poland i like the way i feel i
believe that we feel differently
different places make it feel in a
different way and in poland i just
feel fantastic for a number of reasons
so i like speaking the language i want
to improve the language i have a lot of
friends there i love the country in
general i love the way i feel in poland
and oh there's an important thing too
it's scorching rome so in poland it's
much better in july and august and every
time i go there it's just like so
relaxing compared with
here because in rome is beautiful but in
july and august stay away from it
because it's like 40 degrees
celsius i don't know in fahrenheit but
you know these reasons and and many
others push me to go to poland every
summer or almost every summer
so uh what else let me see if you have
any other questions here
i think you have a lot so
before i before i go through these
questions i wanted to read another
a few questions here
oh by the way yeah interesting yoga with
a son would you recommend speaking of
rome would you recommend
living in rome for a polyglot my my
answer
short answer is yes in the sense of rome
is a cosmopolitan city so you have a you
know compared with small villages
there's a lot of foreigners here but
it's not as cosmopolitan as
madrid or london or paris so
but again i don't think you would move
to rome just to
speak foreign languages and it also
depends on how you live so in rome
uh even if it's less cosmopolitan than
say paris
if you live a solitary life then you
know
that's that's what counts as the number
of connections you make and how you live
that's that's what counts the most
but of course being in any european
language uh
sorry being in any european city is more
than enough to get to know a lot of
people if you
know how to get to know people so uh
um debunker of fake polyglots
uh this is a provocative question uh
what do you think of fake
uh youtube polyglots like valtter
um i gotta confess i made a video about
that and i said that
i think that you know questioning
whether
a polyglot is fake or not is a waste of
time
as always to your time it's always the
my time i think that vouter like anybody
else
everybody has something to contribute to
so if you decide to look at any video on
youtube
with the attitude of learning something
instead of criticizing
then you're going to grow if instead you
spend a lot of time criticizing
and you're not going to spend a lot of
time learning anything that you do
anything any negative you know activity
you engage it
in or any negative thought you have is
less time and less mental space for
positive stuff
you can use to grow your to to grow
in life so um
let me see here um hey luca could you
please hold a stream in different
languages you master perfectly as i said
i don't master anything but
i do speak spanish well and uh that's
the next one
arson i said it at the beginning of this
q a if i'm not wrong and i said it
at the end of the other q a that the
next one is going to be next
five probably are going to be in spanish
then we're gonna do a batch in italian
then in french and then all the other
languages um
so
so let me see here um
so many people learning german here
laila says
yeah there's a lot of people learning
german i have a lot of students a lot of
italian students learning german who
migrated to switzerland or to germany or
austria it's amazing the number of
italians a number of native speak
of foreigners or foreigners of people
who are learning german and personally i
love
teaching training people i'm not
teaching anything i'm training people to
learn german it's one of my favorite
languages together with russian
ah let me see
uh matteos posado how do you tackle
learning a language that uses a
different alphabet do you have any
tricks that are specific to this thanks
for your for your videos but now i do
have a couple of tricks up my sleeve
one suggestion is to download whenever
you can the
you know a keyboard in so that you can
type as soon as possible
then it really depends on the language
for for example for japanese and chinese
i would not start trying to hand write
unless this is a specific skill that you
want to build because it takes so much
time it's a skill on its own
but um the thing i would suggest is that
you download a keyboard so that
you know you reduce the friction of actu
of typing
and i do know one thing or two about the
friction of typing
i always recall and and talk about
retail this uh this episode when i was
i started learning russian then i i was
just painstakingly type
putting every single letter in 2004
i still feel like a fool thinking about
that but
that you know i almost ran the risk of
not you know
literally not continuing
you have to find ways to reduce the
friction and to make stuff fun
so once you download a keyboard it's
possible for example if you go to google
input tools or
if you have a mac or a pc nowadays you
can very easily
install a keyboard and then make sure
that you go on google you
write layouts i don't know thai layout
russian layouts and then you print it
you keep it next to you and you play
you you type sentences instead of typing
simple words
sentences that you like you form
sentences so you have fun and you start
learning in a natural way
that's what i would do when it comes to
learning a language with a different
script
when you start typing you start also
memorizing the stuff
and when it comes to reading stuff i
would use
transliteration i will learn well
the to create i would i would focus on
building a really a good relationship a
good bond a solid bond between how the
language is spoken and how the
transliteration system works
so the transliteration in a way it's a
language on its own
you know so for example just to give an
example z and
h in chinese is pronounced
so in your mind when you see the
transliteration see the ping ying it's
called buffalo morphe it's called in
taiwan
so you see the transliteration then in
your mind when you listen to it
your mind starts building this bond
between the sound ju which is a reach
reflex sound your your tongue goes
touches the palate and this z
and h just to give an example so reading
and listening a lot
using the transliteration first and
typing a lot for fun and reproducing
sentences of the of the stuff that you
read and listen to and build upon that
upon that if you want to learn
how to handwrite then you can do it if
you want to but it's going to take more
time and it's a specific skill on its
own especially when it comes to
languages that use
ideograms for example like chinese and
japanese which are the most difficult
ones in the world in this regard even
languages such as
like korean are not that difficult or
arabic or russian or greek
or georgian so um
hey luca what uh with that much of
speaking practice what's your verbal
top speed have you ever tried to measure
it it's usually it's usually
syllable per second in spanish i think i
speak even faster
in english especially now and speaking
slowly but in real life actually speak
way faster in all these you know in all
the languages
but i i don't think that that speed is
that important i like
i i actually like i i like measuring my
typing speed i i realized i type very
fast or
way faster than the average but for as
as for the
um you know this the speed
uh at which i speak i've never really
measured but it's an interesting
question
never thought about it so um
so so so let me see um how to learn
german give some suggestions and
channels to learn is it possible to
learn two languages at the time please
reply
love from india how to learn
german is a very broad question like how
to learn a language so
uh you know we don't have time to go
specifically into this but
i've made a video about how i've learned
german so you have all the answers there
because it's a story my story with
german it's in german but it has
english and german subtitles but the
bottom line is that when you if you want
to learn any language
and and you know german is one of them
you just have to find a good resource to
start with that is comprehensible in my
case in your case
i would suggest asimil asimov german is
just fantastic
you can start with that for three months
you can go back and forth you can
experiment the way to use it i normally
use my bi-directional translation
technique and by the way there's a big
surprise coming in the next month
and that's why i you know we're running
we're we're grappling with my team also
with
a lot of projects um and use
a way to you know to use this language
learning resource
well to build a reason to build a solid
base and then you can start
venturing into using platforms and
whatnot always making sure that you
create your own language learning
material that is fun
for you if you want to know more about
the resources for german you can go to
lucalampero.com we have
a bunch of resources there for beginners
and intermediate learners
youtube channels included and we're
going to add more and
more as time goes by
so uh fabri fabricio messi
interesting name uh why did you choose
to learn american english instead of
british english sorry for my english
english is great um just because
at the age of at the ripe age of 12 i
came into contact with a lot of native
american english speakers basically
americans
my first tutor was from chicago and then
i consumed she
she gave me a lot of homework and i you
know i was watching
american movies all the time and then
you know i was
um i also was briefly in a relationship
with an american girl they're all from
chicago all these girls from chicago
and and you know that's how i've learned
english i didn't really choose anything
it's just american english that chose me
or the ladies
chose me and they spoke to me in
american english
so um eliseo
what has been the most difficult
language feature you've faced so far i
said it before at the beginning it's
syntax
so it's syntax and japanese in
particular the way they form
sentences and that threw me off and made
the whole thing very difficult again
i think that kevin has left a link to
the video
so why i failed learning japanese or my
failure with japanese i don't remember
the title uh why do you consider that
reading literature is more difficult
than reading essays marco cuevas asked
another question
i think it's because narrative implies
um you know
the very depending also on the writer
descriptive
language that you don't find so much in
in non-fiction books if you if you read
a book
if you read two books one of nonfiction
one fiction
you will quickly realize in a language
you still don't master well
you will quickly realize what i mean
sorry i'm not going very much in depth
with this because we still have
five minutes actually we're going to do
some more uh given also the amount of
people and the amount of amazing
questions you're asking me guys you're
great
um we will keep this we will keep going
for 15 more minutes
so we'll finish at 6 10 p.m central
european time
so let me see
[Music]
do you prefer studying a language by
yourself or by
taking courses i prefer learning a
language by myself but i
don't i don't disdain um going to a
language school actually i've never gone
to a language school but
this summer in september
mr corona allowing i should go to greece
and spend two weeks
in cedus and on this island to do a
couple of weeks in a language school
course so
it's i i do it more you know to to to
spend time
in greece and get to know people than
anything but i i spend a lot of time
learning by myself and then
having private tutors and then you know
if i want to i
like in this case i go to uh i can go to
a language school but
language schools and cherry on on top so
it's
i i don't learn going i don't i don't
follow courses online basically or
offline um
any advice to learn english a vowel
sounds minor
just giving me an idea i don't have time
to go through this now
again because we're running out of time
but there are some resources that i
share with my i've shared with my tutors
there's a very interesting diagram or
there's a very interesting system
which is alternative to the standard the
traditional one
and we're going to post this resource in
the
uh english section english resource
section that we're building because
we're figured out actually and
there are thank you uh for you know to
some of you for pointing that out that
we have a lot of
languages but we don't have english so
we took things for granted and we will
post
some stuff for uh for improving your
english pronunciation grammar and syntax
and
vocabulary and whatnot and other
resources
uh erin what's your thoughts what are
your thoughts on the pimsleur
method um yes english is hard to
pronounce that's true one of the most
difficult languages in the world
um my thoughts are
that i do not know pimsleur i've never
used it
i've used it very briefly for a little
bit but i can't really say much because
i don't know it in
in depth unfortunately so
let me see there's a lot of questions
pouring in um so
do you like to be taught or autodidact
david rodriguez both i like learning by
myself and i like talking and
interacting with people and especially
with my tutors and getting feedback
so i think both are important but uh
language learning is a personal road i
engage a lot in activities that i do by
myself but then at the end of the day if
i look back all the languages that i've
learned to fluency are languages in
which i've engaged in all sorts of
activities learning by myself
and learning through and with others
so let me see
i think i wanted to answer one more
question here
actually despondent being which is a
very interesting name asked me a bunch
of questions i'm going to answer
three out of four the first one is you
know
it would take me an hour to to reply to
that question
how do you memorize so many words in
different languages and don't forget
them the short answer is that i
i design a system where i tend to use
these languages and in our brain we have
a mechanism which is called the survival
of the busiest if you
the more you use something you know the
stuff that we use
thrives stuff that we do not use withers
exactly like a flower so i make sure
that on a daily basis or on a weekly
basis i try to use as many languages as
i can where i try to come into contact
with these languages by
building habits like reading newspapers
books or engaging in certain activities
watching the news speaking with friends
so that i can keep the you know the
storyline
active and if i keep the storyline
active in my brain then
it holds together the vocabulary we tend
to think
as vocabulary as all these like pieces
of content that you have to remember
that that fly everywhere but
remember and i and i keep going back to
this concept of the
the storyline memory works we
we are very good with stories and
speaking languages building a story in
your head so keep that in mind
and the second thing is that i have a
system
that allows me to review things
efficiently that is not overwhelming i
use a system that is
made of fundamentally used notebooks and
a few other things here and there
and i found this to be especially
useful and efficient for me and also
with the
tutors sorry with the students that
have specifically asked me about this
system i
will make a video about that in the
future i i think i already filmed
one or it's we are in the process of
filming it
are you not interested in learning any
ancient language would you take
uh would you take on one and if so then
which one
i have i learned latin at school i have
a couple of books here i love latin i
started learning uh modern greek but
then i gave up because
uh this the agostini course for german
came out and i thought german might be
more useful
how does oh and i have a and i have a um
i have an acid meal with hieroglyphs for
ancient egyptian but i don't know maybe
i'm going to tackle that
but not not now not in the near future
how does
learning progressing and maintaining so
many languages mess
with your life in other aspects
disadvantages of being a polyglot
the max level of languages you can learn
to a high level say c1 c2 and maintain
them this is a very similar question to
the one that was asked before
by solo hanson always no han solo or
something along those lines
and my answer is that there are no
disadvantages there are just advantages
of speaking multiple languages the only
disadvantage if you want to call it that
is that you have to maintain
a number of languages the more languages
you learn the more languages you have to
maintain
and that entails that you have to make
choices
and if you do not think the language
learning is an integral or an important
part of your life or that matter
then your languages are going to suffer
and maybe you're going to suffer
because you don't speak these languages
or you're losing these languages say or
you don't speak these languages as you
used to speak them before
but the bottom line is that there are no
no disadvantages to being a polygon
there are just advantages in terms of
your mental
your mental prowess your ability to
process thought to speak
to understand the the different nuances
i wouldn't go so far as to say to
understand the nook every nook and
cranny of
any culture because it's impossible but
there are so many
you reap so many if it's so many
benefits from learning a language that
is just amazing and if you learn two or
three
or four then you know old doors open up
the world is at your feet maybe not the
universe but at least the world
and um
i'm gonna read another question by
suhaib i think that's his name sorry for
butchering it
is it a bit easier for people who are
who are fluent in english to learn dutch
dutch and and they say that dutch is one
of the most that the easiest language
uh languages in the world for native
english speakers and i they're very
similar
so yes if you already speak dutch
english fluently
whether it's your native language or a
foreign language then learning dutch
is definitely going to be you know not
not a piece of cake but it's not going
to be that difficult
that pronunciation can be tricky but
apart from that i think the language is
pretty straightforward
let me read another couple of questions
from this very same paper here
luka make a video recommending us books
please ali khalid
and we are building i think
um kevin is working on it right now
we're building a
resource section of book resource
section on
the lucanopal.com so stay tuned check it
next week because we're gonna put
my favorite books we're starting with 30
books that have changed my life in terms
of productivity language learning
language in general uh psychology and
whatnot so the books that i've made the
person i am today together with other
things
and you can check those uh starting from
next week probably starting from
tomorrow if we get to
get if getting gets to finish in time um
last question here last two questions
actually are you available on
itokai or italki i never know how to
pronounce
this uh this thing i
am not on aitokai i gave my own uh
one-on-one coaching sessions you can
find the services
and all the information about that in
the uh mukunov.com
in the service section sorry for the dog
barking i don't know if you can hear it
it always starts at six just amazing uh
every single day what are your language
what are your language plans for
three for the next three years i don't
know as i said i'm gonna learn serbian
in september most probably and then um
you know let's see what life
brings about but i already bought a book
in hebrew turkish
arabic and we will see are you planning
to make more videos without our
polyglots the answer
is yes and we'll see with whom do you
have if you have any suggestions guys
just write them there and we will see
because i know a lot of polyglots but
maybe there are other polygons and
interesting people out there i am not
aware of and please uh let me know uh
and uh from this piece of paper and then
i'm gonna come back to you guys
um mali fitness my friend here's my
question what are your thoughts on
language fossilization
is it real fossilization or
fossilization i'm not sure
is it real if so should we delay
speaking until
after receiving massive input things
um i am not sure what you mean exactly
by language fossilization
in term maybe in terms of mistakes
because you're addressing two different
things i would say that
uh you know for as the second part of
the question i would say if you when it
comes to speaking it depends on a number
of factors i would say
talk whenever you want to talk when you
feel ready
and depending on the language if you
speak if you're learning a language
which is very similar to your own native
language or a language you already have
under your belt
maybe you can wait for three months
before speaking and if it's a language
that is more difficult more distant
maybe it can take six months nine months
even one year even two years
if you don't feel like speaking from the
very beginning the bottom line is before
you talk
in order to speak you have to speak a
lot but before you talk make sure you
get enough
input even if with languages that are
very very similar like portuguese in my
case is an italian
it it i would say at least three months
of massive input before you start
talking because
you can't get something out if it
doesn't first get in
somewhere so i'm going to address a few
other questions here before
i leave you guys um
richard simcode a classic hans martinez
said yes i'm
i i've been i've been we i recently
talked with richard and we've been
uh toying with the idea of making
another
multilingual video for you guys if you
find it interesting but we don't just
maybe don't want to talk just about how
we learn languages if you have
you know the moment we decide to do it
we'll ask you hey guys what kind of
questions do you want and if you want we
can do it live
you know this is another idea to do this
finally live where
you know you ask a question i answer he
answers and then you know we get back to
you guys
uh kev kev jackson says pronunciation
can be fossilized yes
when i was he i think that mali was
asking two different questions one is
whether to speak at the beginning
or wait and then fossilization is about
you know
pronunciation i would say in that
fossilization does exist and it
no it doesn't only concern pronouncing
like pronunciation but also any other
aspect of
any other aspect of the language so
in order to avoid that i would always
say
like prevent is always better than cure
preventing is always better in curing
meaning that if you start from the
get-go and you start
addressing some peculiar important
aspects of
the phonetic fabric of a language and
then you get them right then
everything goes goes downhill everything
is downhill meaning that everything is
going to be easier
and on the other hand if you get the the
wrong patterns then it's going to be a
little bit more difficult
to fix them along along the path and
with time because they get more and more
fossilized and
human beings are not very good they're
very good at learning but they're not
really good at unlearning things to
learn them in a different way
uh let me see luca what do you think
lots what do you think lots of people
are mentioning the so-called fake
polyglots
um because there's a lot of people
talking about nowadays fake polygons or
people
who are um kind of busting others
or we're trying to put down others
because they think they're like selling
stuff or
because they're not as good as they
think they are and i state to my i stick
to my
to my guns here and meaning
reiterating what what i was saying
before i think it's
really irrelevant i think everybody has
something to offer
and nobody can be scammed without your
permission in a way
like for example if you buy a course
from a guy right you think he's the
ultimate polygon and then you find out
that is that his material is not as good
then you can always ask for
a refund and that's it i always believed
that instead of complaining
people should focus more on learning and
on the positive aspect of
of of what people can offer but that's
my view and everybody's entitled to
their opinion if
people want to spend time talking about
fake polyglots so be it but
you know uh it's up to me it's not that
interesting
um so um i'm canadian
in school we are taught what we're
taught to write french and not speaking
how can i improve like specifically
pronunciation
well you talk to people and you get
feedback i would hire a tutor
the best would be to hire a coach or to
hire us a person and to ask them to
correct your feedback and then to
re-listen and to try to get your
feedback
you try to improve use leverage that
feedback in order to improve i know it's
a little bit simplistic
i have made maybe kevin can share this
i've i've shared
again videos and articles about how to
improve your pronunciation so please
make
check my my youtube channel and my
website for
articles and podcasts and and youtube
videos related to pronunciation
that we know each other i mean on the
internet and i know you live in rome
not far from where i live
thanks for um you know to everyone for
being so awesome
there's a lot of recurring questions
about learning remembering new words
and um you know i've talked about this
during
this about this during this section
so i think guys that
as much as i would like to stay here the
whole day because this is very
interesting
i think we have i have to go my team and
i have to go
and thank you so much for all the
interesting questions now
i um as i said we're going to start
you know these q a live sessions in
other languages the next one is going to
be in spanish because a lot of people
have requested that
as much as i would like to do a super
super duper cool
culti multi-lingual uh q a session
it's gonna be not very if it's not
feasible for a number of reasons because
if i speak a language and the other
people don't understand but
i will start making them in different
languages um
again uh thank you so much
for uh for all the for all the questions
rehearsal you really want to date him
leila says to nicolas
i don't know what what she is referring
to exactly
um so um
la proxima italiano por favor as i said
i'm just going to do this the next one
is going to be in spanish and then i
think the next one will be in the
the next batch of five will be in
italian
but we can always decide to do one in
english one in spanish
one in italian we will see guys it's
been amazing i love you
for all the enthusiasm the the right you
know the all these
wonderful comments and questions and
curiosities that you have
and thanks for being around so numerous
like you're 244 as of now it's just
amazing
um i hope this was useful as always i do
it to by team and i we do
everything we can to help you guys in
your language learning endeavors
and to give you as much uh you know
advice as we can
and i will see you in a month again i'm
gonna be traveling i don't know if
i can use this beautiful cannon that i'm
using here i might
have to stick to a a camera that is not
just as good but i will uh i will
make it happen somehow and from some
part
of europe thanks so much have a
fantastic day
and rest of the day wherever you are or
the night
and i will talk to you soon bye and
as always thanks for watching and happy
language learning